-Hello, Kelly!
-Hello!
-It is so --
-Oh, I'm trying to fix this.
There we go. Is that good?
-Oh, that's so great.
-I'm so close! [ Laughs ]
-You're so close, but I --
You're not close enough
for my money.
I would of course much rather
see you in person,
but we're doing what we can.
-I know.
I'm, like, one of those people
that likes to hug,
so this is definitely
not my cup of tea.
-And I should say when I --
I went out to L.A. and I was
a guest on your show once,
and it is an incredibly warm
atmosphere, unsurprisingly,
that you have built
in that show.
I know you're coming back to
do a second season like this,
with guests remotely.
How are -- How are you guys
going about it?
I mean, we have
a limited crew here.
I'm assuming it'll be
the same for you.
-Yeah. I mean, all
the restrictions you get,
everybody's tested all the time
like crazy.
Everybody's wearing
all the gear --
and, even myself,
unless I'm, like, on stage
and, like, working.
And it's --
You know, we have virtual --
You know, we have people
coming in virtually, like this,
like, in an interview,
and then we also have --
We're allowed like one,
tops two, I think,
on the stage with us, and we all
have to be so far apart.
Luckily, I have a big stage,
so that's possible.
And then our audience
is, like, virtual.
But it's kind of cool
in the sense --
Because we've had people
from all over the world, now,
at the show, and usually
it's, you know, whoever can --
could've flown to L.A.
and whatever.
But now we've had people
from all over the world, like,
sitting in the audience, and
I'm getting to talk to them,
and they're interacting
and everything.
So that's actually pretty cool.
But it's -- You know.
It's like your crew.
We don't have everyone back yet.
And it's -- We're definitely --
Everyone's working
a little harder, obviously,
to make it work.
But I think it's good that all
our people have work, you know,
and we're trying to get people
back as safely as possible
just so -- I mean,
this is a big financial crisis
for a lot of people.
-It's both wonderful
to have a crew back.
It's both wonderful to
have you back for an audience
that has, in a very short time,
come to love your show.
And I should congratulate you
since I last saw you.
You guys won a Daytime Emmy.
Congratulations.
-We did!
We were so excited!
-I would imagine.
-I didn't even
get to, like, see it.
I feel gypped.
I totally missed it.
And I was called,
and it was hysterical, actually,
how I found out.
Because I was just with my kids.
I was honestly building Legos,
and it was a masterpiece.
But I'm used to being
at the awards show, so you --
You never watch them
because you're there.
So, anyway, so that was --
I feel gypped for
my first-time-ever Emmy.
So, yeah, that was
really awesome because we --
You know, we're still
finishing up our first season.
And, man,
what a first season it was.
What a way to start
a TV show. 2020.
-Have they managed to get you
the Emmy in the mail yet?
Has it shown up?
-No.
I'm so excited, though.
I -- I'm literally --
I'm going to rub it in.
I think just going to bring it
and set it on my "Voice" chair.
-Yeah.
-Like, at "The Voice."
And just be like,
"Oh, one of these?"
Well, actually,
I guess John has one.
He's got an EGOT.
He's, like, an EGOT winner.
I just want to be an EGO.
I just want an Oscar,
so I can have an EGO.
I don't want an EGOT.
-That's true.
I think most people with --
Most people who only have
an Emmy also have an ego,
so you're pretty close.
But for those who don't know,
the EGOT is
the Emmy, the Grammy,
the Oscar, and the Tony.
You are now halfway there.
You've, obviously, won
some Grammys over the years.
What would you say
is most likely to happen next?
Do you feel more confident
about the Oscar or the Tony?
-I'm going to be honest.
I don't feel confident
about either.
[ Laughter ]
I don't live in New York,
so the Tony will be hard.
And, well, I'm not Meryl Streep.
I don't think that's shocking.
So I don't see an Oscar
in the future.
-See?
But there's a lot of paths.
I think you're being
negative about this.
First of all, you just let
somebody make a musical called,
like, "Since U Been Gone,"
and it's just all your songs.
And you basically -- You're just
a producer on that, right?
It still counts.
-Well, then I feel like
you're cheating to get it.
At this point, I'm satisfied
and content with EG.
-Yeah, but, like,
it wasn't like John Legend
won his Oscar
for being in a movie.
You write a song for
a soundtrack. You can do that.
-Okay. I can see
doing a song for it, okay.
But, see, then I'd get the EGO.
-Yeah, there you go.
All right, so we're saying
Oscar is more likely next.
And we're saying you're, like,
98% confident within two years.
-I'm...saying zero percent
never going to get
the other two.